ça veut dire qu'on fait toujours passer
les hommes pour le ceux qui décident ce
qu'ils sont les dominants et c'est alors
que plus de facettes que j'habite et
plus voilà plus discrètes les femmes
au final celle pour le dernier mot et
celle qui décidera fin voilà celle ci
décide oui c'est une histoire à gaz et
bien j'en discutais avec kelly et vers
quoi tu parle de sexe ça se rejoint
sélection pas de savannah et c'est vrai
que on a plus l'habitude et on est
rentré dans une espèce de deux schémas
on attend que c'est l'homme qui fasse
toujours le probable c'est pour ça que
j'ai proposé à agathe deux frères le
premier pas et 2 es2 et d'envoyer un
message à quelqu'un je lui dis
maintenant choisi la personne que tu
savais a dit prends en main on vous
aviez un message et tu verras si et
répond au lieu de tout le temps laissé
venir les âmes non je vais pas envie
retrouver sébastien qu'on attend de
savoir si elle a répondu mais pas
écoutés ben nathan va écouter on attend
c'est vous l'avons envoyé à qui ça
maintenant